yeah welcome to this video playing
DeMarcus Hong Kong sra china okay okay
let's um play the French for change okay
it's going for d3 the Kings Indian
attack now this is an interesting way to
play it some way to get a complicated
position without needing to to know too
much um theoretical details okay
interesting
hmm yeah he's just taking this probably
I need to cover don't want to play b6
really ok what can you do okay boo boo
let's put some pawns in the center
yeah he's trying to to put some pressure
on the d5 pawn
okay yeah I wonder about Bishop a six
should I play maybe Bishop a six okay
let's do that it's interesting not
didn't to recalculate this more more
like a blitz booth trying to prevent
counseling giving away those pawns yeah
can also take him but this was what I
was thinking it's athlete I don't know
it's tricky i hope at least it's
tricking 9f for he may be needs to two
drop it back to our phone and then I was
just thinking to move the Queen giving
away the exchanging it's all about this
this Bishop on a six preventing castling
okay so he's uh oh like before I didn't
jump out didn't consider at all hmm Jeff
yeah this is the problem this is a
problem yeah maybe I need to like I need
to do that it's not not exactly what i
was dreaming about yeah but it's a
somewhat to a team ok so let's uh let's
consider that this is hanging I need
some counter play badly maybe night f5
ok 95 all night a six I take III play 94
and I get this back with an attack I did
it's activating maybe I can just take
the end and move the bishop if you place
let's say king I might just taken and
use the bishop maybe this is enough
compensation it's possible ok you could
take I could take a plane I g-form on
edge for instantly I've 93 2g to this
caption
I knowed you for instantly
it's maybe better interesting very
tricky position yeah I can take I can
take with boobs that can also take with
the gphone night which was one idea of
this III is hanging
check
okay maybe I can just move it now
intending to maybe 93 and okay yes I
didn't mind so much was more afraid that
he would get some some past porn or
something assume that seems this doesn't
seem so dangerous police that further
side okay six pawns he's got two weeks
to porn site two points is a bit much i
tire I thought it was just 12 it's a bit
much and I get one back this is clear g3
but this is still still upon down
okay yeah this was another way to return
the poem I need to get some other pawns
back maybe I get h form yeah not ideal
but they need to catch up a bit on the
clock
new g5 is very ugly Kim
we night fig.3 f5 attacking III
attending Knight f6 so I'm just taking
of course yeah just intending to take
actually why not let's grab it rookie to
coming a day for hanging so I'm now
pulling up from two down or 21 up check
the I spawns a bit a bit more advanced
I've got I've got one more that but
they're connected am this should be
worth something this is just a quick I'm
winning all these pieces check time
morning why did I do that I'm such an
idiot this was so winning ah wine i
cannot i was thinking i can get to e3
with the king but i don't dare Kim it's
it's a draw-game Iran yeah well knowing
that i overstepped the time anyway can
you click with to King III yeah I will
every move one I thought I was just I
was just me scouting I thought I can't I
forgot that it didn't go here I cannot
go here otherwise it would be winning
easily champion I just woke up just need
to be precise let's see how to how to do
that
and isn't it so easy actually hmm what
did I play King f6f this looks normal no
that one yeah he's threatening c6 this a
draw could be
I can't play Bishop d45 yeah this is a
draw hmm this is funny then the nurse
should should winners should win before
and interesting I thought okay in 20
seconds yeah the computer gives this as
winning but this is a bit bit to be too
tricky for this time control the idea is
that Jack this is a really big big
promotion here getting a whole Queen
Jack this is how we played yeah Jack f3
no heaven no I cannot find f3 with 20
seconds yeah a very weird game
complicated game maybe it all this was a
bit too too much night before
interesting what he played here
interesting yeah complicated game I hope
you enjoyed it thanks for watching